[Music]
March of 2017 was a bipolar time for
video games early in the month Nintendo
released the Legend of Zelda breath of a
while to critical acclaim and commercial
success it set a new bar for open-world
titles and propelled the Nintendo switch
to a promising launch on March 21st
however Bioware released Mass Effect
Andromeda it was buggy it was poorly
paced it was a troubling start for a new
chapter in the iconic sci-fi series and
even now after numerous patches and
updates it's still a weak game overall
these two games have something in common
though they were both delayed on several
occasions for various reasons the
studio's behind Zelda and Mass Effect
felt they needed breathing room and
changed their release dates and despite
their differences these projects
illustrate the benefits of delays one
title released when it was finally ready
and the other clearly could have used
more time recently developers rock star
and monolith Studios announced delays
for Red Dead Redemption 2 and Middle
Earth shadow of war respectively and
while this is initially disappointing
for people anticipating those games now
is as good a time as any to take a
closer look at delays to examine how
hard they are to actually pull off and
to discuss why we as players should be
relieved when they happen
[Music]
the video game industry is not what it
used to be
publishers offer deluxe editions season
passes and pre-order bonuses for what
seems like every major game release
we're asked to buy a title months
sometimes a year before we'll ever get
to play it maybe it's because of this
relationship that a stigma has long been
attached to game delays we pay upfront
for a game and all of its future DLC
expecting it on a certain date sometimes
planning other game purchases around it
so when the developer needs more time to
finish the game it can be mistaken for a
broken promise we kept our end of the
bargain so why didn't they this consumer
creator relationship becomes dicey or
when you consider Kickstarter campaigns
rather than release the finished product
to an expectant audience
Kickstarter allows developers to ask for
money up front in turn allowing the
player to be involved in the funding
process itself many creators provide
updates to patrons along the way as
behind the scene rewards or even just to
ensure them that work is being done to
make good on their investment but in
this relationship the creator doesn't
have the same accountability it might in
the traditional sales model here or a
developer can take as much time as it
wants in the creation process promising
a vague release date that could change
at any given moment to be clear I don't
have any inherent problems with this
model some of my favorite games in
recent years began as Kickstarter
campaigns from darkest dungeon to hyper
light drifter to the Banner Saga and of
course FTL but when kickstarter
purgatory grows larger by the year
people begin to notice that their
investments are not coming to fruition
as a February video game project took in
60% less revenue than they did the year
before through Kickstarter of course
we're also in the middle of an early
access craze in theory this is a
fascinating funding model we pay an
arbitrary amount for what we acknowledge
to be a playable but unfinished game
along the way we'll see patches
developer updates and probably added
features ten minutes before writing this
episode I played player unknowns
battlegrounds and dead cells both of
which are in early access on Steam and
both of which are fantastic games
already but like Kickstarter games the
early access model has its own
complications despite the fact that many
games in this category are playable and
missing only a few last minute details
there are others that are nowhere near
complete and have no solid release date
despite being in early
says for much longer than they promised
people who by Enza these games also
assume the risk of these products being
inferior
[Music]
when Mass Effect Andromeda released it
was riddled with bugs clunky animations
broken quest lines janky controls and
myriad glitches soon after Bioware
Montreal released a statement saying
that it would fix Andromeda over time
yes a Mass Effect game released at full
price and its creators said it would
improve it as it goes now I understand
that games aren't what they used to be
many of them serve more as platforms
than traditional games destiny and
overwatch come to mind but when an RPG
developer releases a buggy triple-a game
knowing full well that it will have to
fix not support fix a game after launch
shows major flaws in the system people
paid $60 maybe more in some cases to
play Mass Effect on March 21st and
instead got a buggy mess that would only
gradually become the Mass Effect they
expected
[Music]
I don't mean to keep kicking Mass Effect
while it's down I know the studio
underwent numerous personnel changes and
management problems throughout the
course of Andromeda's development I
don't know the full story but I know it
wasn't the ideal environment for a team
to make a quality game and I know how
hard it is to actually delay a game
Andromeda itself was delayed several
times and during that process I was
happy the internal studio problems were
a clear indicator that the developer
needed more time and I'm sure a lot of
thought and pivoting went into those
delays marketing campaigns are planned
months sometimes years in advance for
Triple A games much of any given
campaign is structured around a specific
release date and changing that date can
throw a whole campaign off furthermore
much of triple-a development is
interwoven between studios members that
work on one title may be scheduled to
work on another as soon as their current
project releases triple-a development is
also very much a cascading structure
where the money made from one game
largely goes into making the next the
delay a game too much could cost
personnel and funding for the next
project the team wants to pursue all of
this is to say that game delays are in
no way a simple strategy for a developer
or publisher they cost money time and
resources so for a developer to take a
closer look at the project they've spent
years on and tell us that they need more
time to realize their vision should be a
great thing I'm not upset about shadow
of war getting delayed or a Red Dead
Redemption - getting pushback because
I'm looking forward to hopefully playing
these games in a finished state when
they do release
[Music]
you've likely played at least one if not
most of these games and for good reason
they're all fantastic some of them are
close to perfect and yet they were all
at one point or another delayed the
cause of those delays range from famous
to obscure the story of half-life 2's
development for instance has become the
stuff of legend years of broken promises
legal battles and scheduling problems
led up to the final release reasons for
breath of the wilds delay on the other
hand are a bit more opaque Nintendo just
didn't think the game was ready and so
it held on to it but of course we don't
remember all of these games because of
their delays we remember them for what
they are now they're classics there look
- as examples of how amazing games can
be their Testaments to the power of
games as a creative medium over their
value as a business industry I think
there needs to be more trust between
creators and consumers between
developers and the fans playing their
games I think we need to understand that
when Rockstar delays read that
redemption - or monolith delays Middle
Earth shadow of war that is a difficult
choice and most likely not a bad thing
for us at all in fact it's largely the
opposite it's - creators saying their
work isn't ready for the people who want
to play them it's - developers saying
yes video games are a business but
they're also a creative medium in art
form and we want to release the best
possible version of this project we're
pouring our lives into we want our time
to be worth it and we want to make your
time worth it too
[Music]
hey everyone thanks so much for watching
episode 8 of reboot this was actually
the last episode of season 1 we're
taking the week off next week to go down
to Los Angeles for e3 but in a couple
weeks when we come back we will start
season 2 so as always get your questions
and comments in but this time tell us
not just what you liked or didn't like
about episode 8 tell us what you like
about the show anything you could
comment on critique we'll talk about
that and our next episode we'll see you
then